today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
welcome everybody it's been a very long
night it is the first day
after the 2020 presidential senate and
house election
and unfortunately we really don't have
that many results
yet at least not enough to say
who will be the president of the united
states for the next four years and it's
really difficult to do these shows
because things
move so quickly and then nothing happens
for hours and things move quickly and
because
it takes us about 90 minutes to produce
the show
i try in the interests of getting you
all
the most updated and accurate
information on which we can then
go to the next day it becomes tough to
know exactly when to do the show but at
a certain point
we have to do it and we're doing it
right now so i will give you the
information that is accurate as of
this moment some of this may have
changed and if so at our next
opportunity to be together we will
discuss it
there is not yet a winner in the 2020
presidential election
i will look at specific numbers with you
in a little bit
but as of this morning the associated
press had it 238 electoral votes for
joseph r biden
jr the democratic candidate and 213
electoral votes for donald trump
and yet donald trump declared victory
late last night early this morning i
will have clips of that
for you that is exactly as i predicted
but the most
important reminder i have and this was
starting to become an issue on last
night's stream
we anticipated this scenario we had um
uh over one and a half million different
people including nearly a hundred
thousand at a time
watched the live stream of the results
last night
and panic was rapidly rising i had
people in europe calling it was four
five in the morning there they were up
all night watching the numbers
we have to remember the red mirage
scenario now
trump may win biden may win this was an
election
because we knew that there were going to
be
postal delays partially caused by the
president's postmaster general
there are now 300 000 potentially
missing ballots which i will tell you
about
i will tell you all of what is going on
some states
which count in person and report
in-person ballots first
and then start counting the mail-in
ballots we knew of a potential red
mirage scenario where states would
look like they were going trump and as
the ballots are counted
they start looking towards biden we
already have two examples of this
wisconsin and michigan they are not
final numbers yet but wisconsin and
michigan
all night yesterday even until midnight
and later
were looking like wow trump's crushing
michigan
and slowly but surely the numbers have
shifted and are now
leaning in favor of joseph r biden jr so
panic does not serve us well in these
situations
we don't think clearly when we're
panicking and importantly
we're panicking over things we can't
control
if we learn about ballots being thrown
out then yes we activate
and we start calling the people who need
to be called
and complaining and making a lot of
noise but merely waiting for ballots to
be counted when we anticipated a red
mirage scenario
doesn't serve us well and in fact as i
tweeted last night around 12 30 in the
morning
remember how we were warned about a red
mirage
and not to panic at midnight on tuesday
i'm going to bed many vote counts don't
even resume
until the morning and indeed that's what
i did
and indeed as the vote counts have
resumed the numbers have started to
shift in joe biden's favor in a number
of states
i'm speaking generally now i will get to
specifics in the next segment
now as a quick reminder in the midst of
all of this remember
we still have a pandemic we had another
nearly hundred thousand cases yesterday
and on top of all of the normal delays
that can sometimes happen
on top of the delays that we're aware of
in the mail on top of all of these other
things
most states are also being relatively
safe when it comes to the pandemic in
terms of election staff
and counting and all of these things so
let's not forget about that reality
as we discuss the election results so
momentarily we're going to do a deep
dive into the presidential map
in terms of the senate we still don't
know who will control the senate right
now democrats have flipped two seats
john hickenlooper won in colorado and
mark kelly defeating the incumbent
republican
vile republican martha mcsally in
arizona
republicans have also flipped one seat
we expected that democratic senator doug
jones would lose in alabama
and he did so that's democrats plus two
republicans plus one that is one seat
in the direction of democrats so far
otherwise counting
continues in the house of
representatives
votes still being counted as of one
moment
earlier today democrats securing 190
seats flipping
two from republicans republicans
securing 181
flipping six meaning a net gain of
four for republicans with 64 seats
remaining to count
i'm going to take some time to go
through
the presidential numbers in a moment
this is going to take some time
as long as we're confident in the votes
being counted
it doesn't bother me although i
understand it is stressful and anxiety
producing
the problem we're up against is donald
trump is trying to end the election now
donald trump has declared victory donald
trump declared that he won states which
it's not
actually clear that he won and we know
of hundreds of thousands of votes that
are potentially missing and we're going
to cover
all of it for you today let's now get
into
the thick of it as we might be calling
it
we are going to now look very very
closely and i'm going to put it up on
the screen because i think that this
we're at a point where this is really uh
the only way to do it
we are going we are going to look at
what we know and what we are waiting on
when it comes to this election now as i
said
currently we are looking at numbers of
joe biden
uh 238 and in fact i think i might might
even have a better view of this for you
uh no i don't not necessarily let me
actually see if i can
there we go i think that's going to be
better for us perfect
right now officially the count is 238
for joe biden 213
for donald trump now as a reminder in
the map
i had for you guys yesterday i did not
believe that joe biden was going to win
florida i did not believe that joe biden
was going to win georgia
i did not believe joe biden was going to
win ohio and in fact i even had arizona
for donald trump so relative to my map
from yesterday
looking only at things that have been
called
joe biden is actually doing better than
i had everything that has been called
has been called as i predicted other
than arizona
which i had for trump and has gone to
joe biden
now the areas of concern
joe biden right now is 32
electoral votes shy of the 270 that he
needs
georgia has not yet been called but i
never believed
georgia was going to go for biden i
believe it will eventually go for donald
trump
north carolina is our first trouble spot
i believed carol
north carolina would go biden right now
with 94
reporting donald trump is ahead by 1.4
now if you were on my live stream late
last night
you might notice that these numbers are
identical to the ones that we had last
night
we don't exactly know what's going on in
north carolina different states are
starting to count
absentee ballots in different ways on
different cycles
but the numbers have not moved in north
carolina there is certainly the
expectation that there
are some strong biden areas left to be
counted but we do not know now i will
get to the math implications momentarily
pennsylvania is an extremely important
state for us to look at
because pennsylvania is now plus
10 for donald trump but you will notice
not even two-thirds of the votes have
been counted and this is where i want to
do a deep dive with you guys before
and i hope that this is not i hope this
isn't boring to people i think this is
actually really important to do
pennsylvania is of massive importance to
joe biden why
pennsylvania's worth 20 electoral votes
if biden gets them it puts him at 258
meaning he needs only 12
more 12 more meaning that wisconsin and
nevada would do it
or michigan would do it and certainly
north carolina would as well
why are these numbers so slow in
pennsylvania because i told you they
would be
pennsylvania doesn't start counting
mail-in ballots until all
um voting has stopped and if we go
and look at the new york times and zoom
into pennsylvania
this is where the devil is really in the
details
if you look at for example philadelphia
county which contains
the city of philadelphia
you see that only about half the votes
have been counted there
joe biden continues to lead basically
three to one it's about 75
25 even better actually in philadelphia
county for joe biden
only half of the votes have been counted
that alone
if you do just some very very basic math
is potentially a hundreds of thousands
of
vote advantage for joe biden the numbers
there
could close half of the gap that
currently exists
you then look at pittsburgh pittsburgh
which has counted 70 percent joe biden
is up by nine there that could
potentially close the gap
again by 70 000 votes
theoretically allentown has now gone
towards donald trump by a little bit but
there is
a real reason to think that the
outstanding
mail-in ballots in allentown in the
allentown area which is lehigh county
could be very helpful to joe biden so
when we look at the general number and
this is not me blowing smoke
it's just an assessment of what we know
and what we expect
when you look at the numbers in
pennsylvania and you see wow
64 reporting trump is up
10. that seems impossible but then as
you realize
how much there is left to count and you
realize that
a lot of those small rural trump
counties are at 100
reporting and a lot of these dense
democratic
parts are at 50 60 70 percent
with biden's margin being huge
all we can do is count the ballots we'll
know eventually the results
we will know so let's wait on that a few
other
spots to look at wisconsin
wisconsin has now flipped in favor of
joe biden
all of last night wisconsin was read as
they were at 10
15 20 25 30 even close to 50
reporting wisconsin was in the donald
trump column
and those of us who knew about the red
mirage scenario and understood how
wisconsin counts
we expected it would become close when i
went to bed it was red when i woke up it
was blue
it has not yet been called it is a small
margin as of this moment
joe biden is up 21 000 votes in
wisconsin
the reports from people who know
wisconsin remember
we we want to be careful and precise the
reports from folks who know wisconsin
are that the areas left to count with
mail-in ballots
are democratic-leaning areas if i were
looking at this
my expectation would be biden ultimately
is going to get wisconsin
and then lastly michigan michigan also
18 000 votes right now separating the
two candidates
with joe biden ahead we were seeing
panic yesterday
but we were also hearing from michigan
experts who said
look at what's in and look at what's
outstanding this is going to trend
towards joe biden
and it has gone indeed now slightly for
joe biden now
by the time you listen to this maybe joe
biden will have won
there's the idea michigan will be called
today or tomorrow
maybe donald trump will have taken over
and then lastly
nevada nevada has 67
reporting it's worth six electoral votes
joe biden's slightly ahead um and then
it remains with north carolina
we have that same lead of 1.4
as of right now for donald trump and
questions about what is outstanding
there
so when we go to the map and we start
looking at
scenarios again even though georgia has
not been called for trump i believe
he gets it let's now look at this
scenario and also alaska has not been
called for trump but i believe he gets
it that would put us at 238 to 232
in favor of joe biden okay so
what now what now is and let me even
adjust this so that we can get
uh i think i want i want the best we
don't usually do it this way but it's
just so important that i do it
because we are looking at these election
results live i want to have everything
on screen for you
we have a situation where let's imagine
for a second that north carolina stays
with trump
okay that wouldn't be good but i want
everybody to understand that if
trump gets north carolina and even gets
pennsylvania
if joe biden can just hold his leads in
nevada
wisconsin and michigan he wins
and if he were to get the nebraska
second district
that would be 271 biden 267 repub
uh trump and i'll even change these to
say biden and trump
i am not trying to give you unrealistic
scenarios i am merely telling you
biden has a path without pennsylvania
and without north carolina if he were to
get
uh not north carolina but pennsylvania
all of a sudden you can take nevada off
the table and biden still wins
you can even take um you can't take
michigan off the table and that's an
error
well you could take michigan off the
table if biden gets nevada
or if he gets michigan you could take
wisconsin
and nevada off the table and biden still
wins
so my point here to you is what as we
look at these numbers my point is
this was never going to be the blowout
that 538
said it would this is why my map was
very conservative
all along when i was telling people
imagine that your state is 50 50. and
people would email me saying david
you're gaslighting people you're making
people think it's closer than it is so
that they vote
no i'm saying we don't really know
how close some of these states are with
absentee ballots and all of these
potential factors all we know is we have
the opportunity to vote and we should
and now indeed it is going to be
much closer to my map than anything we
got from any of these modelers
so we have to just go through the
process and understand
biden can win without pennsylvania or
north carolina
if he holds his leads in nevada
michigan and wisconsin he doesn't
actually
need north carolina or pennsylvania if
biden gets
north carolina or pennsylvania
pennsylvania being more likely
those results start to look
significantly better
other things that i wanted to look at i
guess the only other thing to look at
here
would be in terms of the
presidency just looking at the popular
vote
is one thing i would look at the popular
vote right now
is almost 69 million votes for joseph r
biden jr
and more than 66 million votes for
donald trump so again
joe biden by the time it's done will
have easily won the popular vote
record vote by the way for uh donald
trump
added about three million votes and
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later that is really really
important
but that is where we are right now so is
it time to panic it's definitely time
for concern
but joe biden has two completely
separate paths to victory
one which includes pennsylvania and or
north carolina
less likely north carolina and one which
doesn't require
either of them which goes through
wisconsin michigan and nevada
count every ballot don't get ahead of
ourselves
we will be here with you let me know
your thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't
have time for if there's a full book
you're thinking about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that these are the times we
really need independent media
i would invite you to grab a membership
at joinpacman.com
the prices are reasonable the company is
friendly
and you really are doing a lot to
support our work when you sign up
uh donald trump exactly as predicted
held an event that was almost like a
rally at the white house last night
something like two in the morning east
coast time
and donald trump says he won donald
trump claims he won the presidency
donald trump claims he won states that
he did not actually win
and trump says that they're trying to
steal it from him they being i guess
democrats you have to see this this is
red alert stuff
this is the stuff of dictators this is
the step to stuff of dystopian
authoritarians this is the exact
situation about which i warned you
donald trump and his family
coming into cheers at the white house
like this
is a victory rally literally as trump's
lead in wisconsin was evaporating
and switching to biden as trump's lead
in michigan was evaporating and
switching to biden
the election results still in question
with multiple paths to victory as of
this moment for joe biden doesn't mean
biden will win but this was not a time
to declare victory so in comes donald
trump
thanks people as if he's one and says
there's an attempt
to disenfranchise his supporters
of course asserting this without
evidence
i want to thank the american people for
their tremendous support
millions and millions of people voted
for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
and we won't stand for it we will not
stand here
there is no evidence that anyone
is trying to disenfranchise trump voters
and in fact
there's evidence of the opposite from
this trump event
which we will get to trump comes out and
says they're trying to disenfranchise my
voters
later trump confirms he's trying to
disenfranchise biden voters and we will
get that
trump as one example is trying to
disenfranchise by claiming he won states
that haven't yet been called
um trump claims he won georgia as i
showed you in our earlier segment
georgia is still counting ballots it is
according to the numbers leaning trump
although the new york times has an
indicator that says it may once atlanta
has counted go biden
the point is he had not won georgia at
this point in time
there's never been anything like it to
support our incredible movement
we won states that we weren't expected
to win florida we didn't win it
we won it by a lot and
we won the great state of ohio
we won texas we won texas
we won texas by 700 000 votes and they
don't even
include it in the tabulations
it's also clear that we have won georgia
we're up by
2.5 or 117 000 votes with
only seven percent left they're never
going to catch us they can't catch us
trump may win georgia in the end but to
claim
at 2am last night as counting in atlanta
had stopped
that he had won is wrong and when he
talks about suppression
that is a way to suppress activism by
saying i already won it don't even worry
about pushing for the votes to be
counted
we have to see what happens when atlanta
ballots are counted
this is trump assuming a victory that he
didn't have
and certainly didn't have last night we
will see if he ever gets it
how things change so quickly though
because donald trump came out and said
at the same event there's a good
possibility that i'll win arizona
biden's margin has grown in arizona
trump touted a lead in michigan
which has flipped now to joe biden trump
said he was winning wisconsin
wisconsin has flipped to joe biden razor
thin margins but they have flipped
now understand this when donald trump
came out last night
he was losing arizona but he was ahead
in pennsylvania
there are far more ballots left to be
counted
in pennsylvania than there are in
arizona but
trump comes out and says we need to keep
counting in arizona
but he says nothing about counting
ballots in pennsylvania
with far more outstanding ballots in
particular
from philadelphia pittsburgh and other
democratic leaning areas take a look at
this
we also uh if you look and you see
arizona we have a lot of life in that
and somebody said somebody declared
that it was a victory for us and maybe
it will be i mean that's possible
but certainly there were a lot of votes
out there that we could get because
we're now just coming into what they
call trump territory i don't know what
you call it but these were friendly
trump voters
and that could be overturned the
gentleman that called it i watched
tonight
he said well we think it's fairly
unlikely that he could catch well fairly
unlikely
and we don't even need it we don't need
that that was just
a state that if we would have gotten it
would have been nice arizona but
there's a possibility maybe even a good
possibility in fact
since i saw that originally it's been
changed and the numbers have
substantially come down
just in a small amount of votes
so we want that obviously to stay in
play
but most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
we're up 600 think of this think of this
think of this
we're up 690 000
votes in pennsylvania 690 000
these aren't even close it's not like oh
it's close
with 64 of the
vote end it's going to be almost
impossible to catch and we're coming
into
good pennsylvania areas where they
happen to like
your president
[Applause]
lots of votes to get in arizona they
must keep counting
and we're winning pennsylvania but only
60 percent has been counted
says nothing about continuing to count
in pennsylvania
and as we told you pennsylvania is a key
state we're suppressing the count
suppressing the mail-in ballots is their
stated strategy it's not
we think they might come up with it's
their stated strategy
and it's because pittsburgh philly and
some other areas that are going big to
biden
stopped counting absentee ballots
overnight they are resuming today
that will hurt trump so trump says
nothing about counting but arizona he
wants the vote to keep being counted
here trump says counting the votes
is a conspiracy against him i wish i had
more explanation it's completely
unintelligible
and you take all of the others i mean we
have we have so many we had such a big
night you just take a look at all of
these states that we've won tonight
and then you take a look at the kind of
margins that we've wanted by
and and all of a sudden it's not like
we're up 12 votes and we have
60 left we won states and all of a
sudden
i said what happened to the election
it's off
and we have all these announcers saying
what happened and then they said oh
because you know what happened
they knew they couldn't win so they said
let's go to court and did i predict this
newt did i say this
i've been saying this from the day i
heard they were going to send out tens
of millions of ballots i said exactly
it's of course been trump who has been
threatening to go to court
i have no idea what he's talking about
it's incoherent
it doesn't make any sense and then
donald trump goes totally in
as he reads vote numbers into the a
fraud has been committed
approach says definitively we did win
this election
remember he didn't win yet he certainly
hadn't won last night he hasn't won as
of right now
and then donald trump starts to allude
to going to the supreme court
to help him by stopping ballot counts
he's doing everything we predicted
so we won there we lead by 76 000 votes
with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and we as far as i'm
concerned we already have for him
so i just want to thank you a major
fraud
we won we will be going to the supreme
court a major fraud there's no evidence
of unless the fraud was perpetrated by
him
and he knows something he's not telling
us we won
not at that point and not at this time
we will be going to the supreme court
maybe and that could be a disaster he's
telling us the strategy he's saying
he wants the voting to stop voting has
stopped
what needs to happen is the counting he
wants you to believe people are still
voting nobody's still voting
any ballots submitted at this point
would not be valid valid
but the ballots that have been submitted
and not delivered yet
must be counted he's done everything it
looked like he would do
he has i i did a segment monday trump
will step up to a podium and claim
victory when there's no victory to claim
he did it
some of you wrote to me said david
you're being hyperbolic he did it
he's alleging fraud by the other side
when there's no evidence of such fraud
he did it
he's saying that he will go to the
courts including the supreme court
that's exactly what we predicted will he
get away with it
is the question we now have to ask the
next
24 to 72 hours will be crucial
i have a very contrasting set of
comments
from the other candidate to play for you
joe biden came out last night before
donald trump around
1am roughly in the morning east coast
time
and he was notable in that he behaved
like a normal person
we didn't know at the time and we still
don't know now who is the winner of the
race
and joe biden doesn't come out like
trump and say
i won joe biden doesn't come out and say
i won states that haven't actually been
called which uh donald trump did
joe biden comes out and makes it clear
we knew it would take a while
and we believe we still have a path to
winning which is true he may not win
but as i showed you earlier earlier in
exquisite detail he does have a path
here's joe biden
your patience is commendable we knew
this was gonna go wrong
but who knew we're gonna go into maybe
tomorrow morning maybe even longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do
[Music]
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
so of course joe biden is optimistic as
any campaign would be until it's clear
you're not going to win
but unlike donald trump joe biden is
being a responsible adult
joe biden is not declaring a victory
that he doesn't have joe biden is not
declaring victories in states
that have not been called and which in
fact as donald trump said were winning
wisconsin and michigan
those states flipped to joseph r biden
jr
notice that joe biden doesn't claim
a victory absent an actual victory to
claim
he doesn't allege fraud absent actual
fraud to claim he doesn't say he will go
to court
to try to stop ballots from being
counted
the contrast is stunning and the fact
that so many americans don't care is a
problem which i am going to get to a
little bit later
increasingly joe biden's path depends on
pennsylvania although as i said earlier
even without it
biden can win with nevada
michigan and wisconsin but joe biden
says they feel good about pennsylvania
this was last night we still have to see
how the numbers come in
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
we're feeling real good about wisconsin
and michigan
[Applause]
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
and as we will uh continue to see
pennsylvania if it were to flip back to
biden
as that remaining 35-ish percent of the
vote is counted
it could be a huge part of biden's path
to victory if indeed he gets it
it would be the ultimate red mirage
scenario major major factor
and then lastly here is joe biden saying
we could know the results as early as
tomorrow morning
but it is not up to him to say when it
is final
it is up to the american people and of
course the people actually counting the
ballots take a look at this
look you know we could know the results
as early as tomorrow morning but it may
take a little longer as i've said all
along
it's not my place or donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
and i want to thank every one of you who
came out
and voted in this election and by the
way chris coons and the democrats
congratulations here in delaware so
the contrast continue if you thought the
the wackiness would stop on election day
you were very wrong
joe biden acting like a normal person
connected to reality not a delusional
narcissist
it's nice for a change donald trump
coming out in a rally-like atmosphere
claiming he won
claiming he won states in which leads
were evaporating
literally as he spoke claiming fraud
and claiming he will go to the supreme
court it's incredible guys
it's incred we need to maintain
our democratic systems and donald trump
is taking
a sledgehammer or a chef's knife or
whatever a sword
anything donald trump could pick up with
those hands of his um
and we need to protect democracy we'll
continue covering this
on instagram where you can find us at
david pakman show
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show so
as of this recording we don't yet know
the winner of the 2020 presidential
election
but unfortunately we can now say with
complete certainty that this
is a country that is screwed whether
trump wins or loses
for a long period of time now i know
some of you won't like this commentary
the votes have been cast there's no more
votes to cast they need to be counted
me saying this now won't change anything
of course
if joe biden becomes president the
country is
able to possibly start reorienting in
the right direction joe biden has paths
to victory
and donald trump has paths to victory it
would be huge for joe biden to become
president we can start to repair global
relationships we can start to
be a little bit less of a global
laughing stock but almost
67 million people have already voted for
donald trump
about 5 million more people have voted
for donald trump this year
then in 2016. win or lose that is a
recipe for a destroyed
country we have to realize that when we
see
coronavirus economy race protests
these are the top issues and trump's not
polling well
in them that doesn't mean that
your average trumpist actually connects
their vote
to what is happening in their state and
says oh
i will then not vote for trump because i
think he's not doing well on these
issues
pandemic running rampant in my state
because our governor
is buddy buddy with trump and they're
ignoring guidelines and opening
everything and having huge events so the
virus spreads and hurts the economy
yeah i do disapprove of that but vote
for joe biden no but
no way i'm voting for donald trump again
win or lose we have not 60 million
but 67 million trumpists who live in
this country
who will continue to live here no matter
who wins the presidential election
my dad has written recently in spanish
about how to understand trumpists
because truly
how do you understand millions more
votes for trump
in the midst of one of the worst
performances in the world on the
pandemic
it doesn't make sense if you are
rational and thinking empirically
the answer as my dad is written is
magical or mythical thinking among his
supporters
trump supporters see themselves at being
as being at war
against the left against democrats
against the media
against scientists against atheists
against communists and marxists and all
of that stuff
they see themselves as at war they also
idealize
violence and these ideas of courage
and risk taking things by force
imposing their opinions because they are
better
and because america is first as they say
so when you understand the mindset when
you're at war
a normal way of interacting with the
world and others
evaporates and you justify as we've seen
actual militaries justify all over the
world
you justify absurd and immoral behavior
in that situation lying is completely
valid if you're at war i mean come on
guys it's a war lies lies are no big
deal we're at war here
and so when they say things like
the virus isn't that serious we wonder
are they in denial um do they not
understand
no no you know they they are accepting
that
listen old folks immigrants stuck at the
border with the virus
weak people with comorbidities they're
going to have to die we are essentially
culling the weak and some of us will die
as well they know some of their people
are also going to die
but it's worth it to win the war which
in their mind
is we must support trump and we must
defend trump at all costs no matter what
those costs are and my dad wrote
it's just like the war approach of we're
going to take some casualties
but it's worth it because we're going to
win the war it's not just wishful
thinking because wishful thinking is
more
individualistic this is really a
mythical thinking it's a cultish
thinking
which is really more of a group
psychology element it's more of a social
force
and each trump cultist sees themselves
as individual agents recruited by the
cause
to push their values and talking points
with any weapon they can
and those weapons include straight up
lies
spreading fake news going out without a
mask
casting a vote for trump even if he
screwed up the pandemic
they're in love with their traditional
sort of
fascistic authoritarian values these are
authoritarians
they are sort of fighting their
stalingrad against the abnormal
as they see it the weak as they see it
and they believe
many of them that god is on their side
everything that seems despicable
to other people who are involved in what
should be a democratic process
it's different when they are already at
war
they are operating under the logic of
war we are operating under the logic
of anti-authoritarianism and democracy
so whether biden wins or not this
problem i've outlined
doesn't go away and what we need to
understand is that
confronting what i just described with
empiricism
argumentation rationality
facts it doesn't account for the reality
that they are in a cultish mythical
magical thinking space they're thinking
of
the myth of this is a war it will never
reach them to say but look at these
facts you understand the facts so how do
we interrupt it
i don't have any any idea let's first
figure out who won the presidency
this is not an election that should be
this close but again because of these
people
this election should be 99 to 1 in favor
of biden based on trump's
actions based on trump's
authoritarianism but that's not how his
supporters even think about the world
the fact that people vote for trump is
in and of itself stunning in a normal
country
um even with a sort of
white nationalist identitarian
nation hyper nationalistic streak
someone like trump wouldn't get more
than you know being generous
30 percent of the vote and it would
probably be more in the teens
here donald trump got nearly 70 million
votes
nearly 70 million votes so i'm getting
ahead of myself because i've said
after the election we will address the
problem of trumpism
first let's figure out who the next
president is going to be the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as we continue to await results in
many states we wonder
how many mail-in ballots are out there
in various states
we are getting news that there could be
hundreds of thousands of
missing ballots missing ballots the u.s
postal service
had a deadline of yesterday to sweep
their mail processing facilities in more
than a dozen states
for missing election ballots because of
reports that ballots were just
sitting around they could be hundreds of
thousands of total ballots when you look
at some of the margins in the states
still being counted
you quickly realize hundreds of
thousands of that ballots could make a
huge difference
u.s district court judge emmett sullivan
in dc
ordered the sweep tuesday morning when
the postal service said
that its delivery performance was down
and they couldn't say whether more than
000 ballots received had been delivered
well then you've got to see if the
ballots are still at the postal center
the sweep was supposed to happen in 12
specific districts
including in arizona florida
georgia pennsylvania texas wisconsin i
think you understand the importance of
this
the judge gave the agency until 3 30 pm
to finish the task
at 4 30 the postal service said sorry
we couldn't do it would have disrupted
our election day
activities they said they would continue
a daily review process
to find and deliver smaller amounts of
ballots
we don't know how many ballots are
currently missing the window
is closing very quickly the deadline for
mail-in ballots
uh depends on what state you were in
but it was tuesday night in a number of
different states
there are reports of undelivered ballots
that have started cropping up even from
the past weekend
miami-dade county listen i'm not saying
anything in particular but miami-dade
county
was expected to be more pro-biden than
the numbers
bore out and miami-dade county is one of
the places where mail-in ballots have
allegedly gone undelivered
i'm just giving you the information this
is a red alert
in pennsylvania alone one of every two
ballots rejected in the last election
were because of a missed deadline
and the margin was only 44 000 votes by
which donald trump defeated hillary
clinton
this has to be taken uh extraordinarily
seriously
this is just one example relating to
potentially 300
000 ballots that we know of look at the
margins
this is a potentially election changing
number of ballots
these ballots could decide a state or
two and
these are exactly the ballots
that donald trump told us at 2am last
night
he is going to go all the way up to the
supreme court if he needs to
in order to stop the counting of these
ballots
and donald trump wasting no time this
morning in starting
the conspiracy theories let's talk about
that next
trump is doing it he is starting to say
there is funny business as he starts to
lose michigan
as he starts to lose wisconsin as nevada
may be beyond repair for him we don't
know
it's early i'm just telling you the
numbers as of this moment
donald trump came out at 2am last night
and he said we won
trump listen guys i hate that we were
right about these things but
i told you monday trump would claim
premature victory when there was no
victory to claim he did it at 2am last
night
trump said he was winning wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania georgia north
carolina
states that had not yet been called we
all knew the reality of the red mirage
scenario of huge numbers of outstanding
absentee and mail-in ballots
and this morning slowly but surely
wisconsin flipped blue small margin
michigan flipped blue small margin
we are anticipating at least a
tightening in pennsylvania as they
resume counting votes although we don't
know exactly how it will go
nevada still in the blue column
so now trump has to do it now he has to
question whether this is rigged
donald trump tweeting just a little
while ago quote
last night i was leading often solidly
in many key states
in almost all instances democrat run
and controlled then one by one
they started to magically disappear as
surprise
ballot dumps were counted very strange
and the pollsters got it completely
and historically wrong he is doing it
the president of the united states is
saying
not just oh there are some
questionable ballots in florida and we
have the paper ballots and it's hanging
chads and we just have to look at no no
no trump is actually suggesting
that swath tranches
we could call them cohorts of
imaginary mail-in ballots
are being fabricated to steal
states from trump the president of the
united states
is making that assertion on twitter um
they are counting ballots we knew this
would happen
many states report in-person numbers
very quickly and then start counting
mail-in ballots and then they stop for
the night and then they start again
i told you that this would happen we
predicted it and i urged
calm i urged calm last night
we have to wait for the ballots to be
counted but now we are up against the
situation where donald trump
is going to try to stop the ballots from
being counted
you have to really zoom out to
understand the authoritarian
nature of what's going on step one claim
a victory you didn't really win
trump may win but when he claimed
victory last night there was no win to
claim
claim you are winning in states that you
are not actually
winning in or where it is at least
unclear
whether you are winning trump did it and
then
when the numbers start to shift you have
your own prior claims to point to listen
i came out yesterday and we were ahead
and i said so and then now it's changing
well
what's inappropriate is not that they
are now counting ballots
what was inappropriate was that he came
out and claimed victories he didn't
actually have the mathematical standing
to claim
so we need to be extraordinarily
vigilant now i
i wish i could come to you and say what
it is that we should be doing
i don't know i don't know if our systems
are strong enough to withstand this
because so far no system has been able
to hold trump accountable
do we need to call our elected officials
who do we call
what do we say what can they do if i
call ed markey
say you know look at what trump's do i
what can ed markey do i don't know i
don't
actually know what to do it is a crisis
situation
so while we need to remain very calm as
far as
we need to wait and see who wins a lot
of these states michigan looked very bad
last night
early for joe biden then it looked okay
as of five minutes ago biden's ahead in
michigan we have to wait
we have to wait and see but the cat is
out of the bag
trump is claiming they are stealing it
from him fraudulently
once that is done it's crossing the
rubicon in a sense there's no one
ringing that bell
if donald trump is starting with that
this early that is what donald trump is
going to go with
and we need to be very much prepared for
it let me know i want to hear from you
what should i be advising the audience
to do to prevent trump from making
credible allegations of fraud when there
is no such evidence
i i wish i had something for you if you
let me know
we can follow up on it tomorrow i i do i
i know that we have a lot of stressful
things going on
as of this moment we don't know who is
going to be the next president of the
united states
but i want to take a moment just to say
something
happy we had an
incredible turnout of force in the
independent progressive media community
yesterday
we set records on every platform our
we estimate that 1.5 million different
people watched
some part of our election results
coverage last night
we had over up to 82
83 000 live concurrent viewers on
youtube
with a sum total of about 1.4 million
different people coming in and out
throughout the evening a record for us
incredible uh ungodly numbers of of
comments and
and messages from everybody just
completely unbelievable
we had four to seven thousand people
throughout the night
on twitch which is another platform that
we've been taking very seriously it's
been a great place to do
politics not historically not the place
for politics more for gaming and other
types of content
we are there and a few others are there
doing politics on twitch an incredible
night
in total view time by far a record on
twitch
um 400 paid subscribers signing up via
the twitch
platform another 400 members signing up
on our website so
the this is what what matters is
do we remove donald trump and we don't
know that yet
but the way that our community has come
out and
spent the evening with us and with me it
was a long night
it was a stressful night during which i
tried to encourage
uh people to to remain calm but
what an incredible evening and um
now the question is can we continue
if we the goal is the idea would be
that if we can remove donald trump we
still don't know we're still waiting on
results if trump can be removed
my goal would be the dream would be
that all of this growth that we've been
experiencing
gives us a much stronger position from
which
to now do progressive activism if we
remove donald trump
we've been playing a lot of defense the
last four years we may have to play
defense for another four
by the time you watch today's show or
listen to this clip you might already
know the winner
but the opportunity is if we can remove
donald trump
to leverage our larger than ever
audience thanks to you
thanks to you really um to get the most
we can
out of whatever opportunity presents
itself
to move things to the left in the united
states so
a huge huge thank you again our estimate
more than 1.5 million different people
joined us
on youtube twitch our facebook stream
and we were also the live
facebook stream for our broadcast
partner free speech tv
really really incredible so we're going
to continue counting vote counting votes
at some point in the next day two three
four days we will have a likely winner
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
for you today i'm told pat
barely slept so we will hear from him
we're going to look at
what we do know from yesterday including
ballot initiatives
including some of the key senate and
house races
and so much more about what to expect in
the coming
sort of like the day the week
the two and a half months until january
20th
and the next four years those are the
different time frames that we're looking
at right now
so come on in grab yourself a membership
at joinpakman.com
it takes very little time you'll get
instant access to the members only bonus
show and there is
much to discuss so i look forward to
seeing you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video